Sushi.
That's a,
I mean it feels like that you want Susan,
I'm some fucking power.
And I'm saying,
can we get,
can we sell it to make some calls?
Calls,
take somebody out to my boy meat into the goddamn states,
but also news.
What does it say?
Well,
we've tried to get this Carmen retired.
Oh Wow.
It seems like their nose.
No.
Insurancing fights and I'm not getting younger.
Let me explain.
Let me just lay my gloves down right here on.
Oh,
he did it on Reddit.
Wow.
Wait.
Why is he done though?
Thank you to each and every one of you.
It's odd to be healthy and unable to compete yet able to compete when so
unhealthy.
I guess we end.
I don't know what that means.
I think he made a mistake there with never.
Oh,
I guess we end with never knowing what could have been
somber would be the best bay to describe the emotion.
Thank you all for the love,
the insults and the great times.
I will sync back into the mode of being a redditor and my quest to become a mod
here.
It was series sort of making a little joke there.
I am also on the hunt for a large fedora.
I'm like an eight and a half and hats,
moderate climates as Shane.
Seriously.
Thank you.
Often bottom of my heart for being an amazing,
if for being amazing and for making this sport amazing.
I thought he was retired.
He was coming back out.
Try and fight.
Did Bell towards just tell him no or something?
Yeah,
I think he just put his name in the hat.
You just called out mitre island.
He just literally two days ago he just said he wanted to fight as the ultimate.
Here's what it's weird.
It says it's odd to be healthy and unable to compete,
yet able to compete when so unhealthy mean it's odd that he's healthy now and he
can't get a fight.
Did they?
That means the commissioner maybe so and told him he kept fight or maybe belt or
was like,
Nah,
we're good son.
Well I would never say he couldn't fight in terms of like the punishment he's
taken.
I mean there's like the junior dos Santos fight was tough to watch.
That was a tough one.
That was a tough one to watch.
He's had some tough fights,
but I mean,
a lot of guys have,
if you're going to let Overeem fight,
how could you not let Shane Carbon fight?
Unless it's like the spinal surgery stuff.
Yeah.
I'm not sure what's going on that,
but,
but also he could fight and rise again.
I would imagine that they would take care.
Bye Amy Buddy.
Bye.
You know that they had an issue with him where he was getting divorced and he
had some personal issues.
Apparently they were saying and he had a pullout of their tournament,
remember?
Yeah.
He ended up fighting.
They were very upset.
They were very upset and he backed out and they said,
they said some things about him,
you know,
not having warrior spirit or some crazy shit like that.
Relax rides and shit happen.
Yeah.
I mean,
not only that,
you don't want to have so many fucking heavyweights.
Yeah.
You're also rising sorts.
Relaxed.
And I'm Shane Carwyn back though.
Half Shane car went over there and a lot of them crawl correction,
but I pop him CurrComm wild west
golden snitch.
Yeah.
Just full on Mexican.
Stop.
Let the party role mix it up.
Especially mean chains in his forties right?
How old is shame?
Hell yeah,
he's in his forties yeah.
Let it roll.
Raisins.
The spot.
I mean,
look,
we should have a steroid league.
We should have a league where some people are not.
Daniel Cormier essays for faces.
Volk on owes Demir at UFC two 20 and Boston.
Ooh.
Ooh,
wow.
Breaking news folks.
Breaking news.
[inaudible] scary.
But there's it.
There's a guy who's got the quickest rise to the top ever.
This my face for that fight.
You don't care.
I care.
I'm lukewarm on it with those.
I love DC.
I love DC and I wish you was a bigger star and he should be a bigger star and I,
but I,
you know,
he's going to be phenomenal as a commentator and I think he flies through those,
the man.
Do you really?
Yes.
Easily think,
oh,
zoom is dangerous for anybody,
man.
Anybody.
Good luck dealing with DC when he gets you in there clinch.
It's true.
He's a monster.
Light heavyweight of all time.
Not named John Jones.
Whoa.
Strong ones.
Who's better?
Nobody.
He was the heavyweight champion twice.
Yeah,
twice beat.
Guthman he was the head of state champion Grand Prix.
Then think about the people in that Grand Prix.
Yeah,
Mary did the Josh Barnett.
The judge Brennan had a broken hand,
but through him up in there,
man,
we did a poor Dan Henderson.
How are the way DC,
how dare you treat our legend like that?
How dare you take an old,
whether Dan Henderson spike him on his head.
You son of a dog.
I mean he ragdolled.
I love DC man.
I liked that fight for DC.
I'm a owes them air fan.
I think be hilarious.
Has Champions this 700 Twitter followers.
But I think that DC is going to mop the floor with him.
Interesting.
Unless it's a barn Florida than stemer story.
I'm just interested in seeing what happens if,
um,
if he gets hit because those demeanor is very fast and hits very hard and has a
shocking reaction.
DC's been hit hard.
Oh for sure.
Rumble,
rumble rocked him.
Rock the rocks in it.
That overhand right in the first fight and the head kicked him in the second
she,
I remarried.
Sat him down cause he popped up.
Yeah,
I'll beat DC is a monster.
No doubt.
I'm just interested because I think,
oh was the mirror really does have special power.
You'll,
you'll,
you'll see him hit people.
You're like cheeses and according to everybody that watched him and rumbled
train,
like he was the guy that trained with rumble all the time.
It's one of the few guys that want to spar with what they say about it.
So they went to war.
Really would watch that,
watch that.
I would watch her mood happy.
That's one of the reasons why those to me are so good.
So that was the was like pump train with the,
and he was like,
everybody's carrying around ball.
The happy,
scared rod it.
They're not just knock each other out every day.
I think they're smart.
They hit each other just hard enough to you like let each other know they're
hitting each other and look,
you want a valuable sparring partner.
I mean if you take your toys,
yeah,
look,
it's benefiting the both of them.
Obviously.
Here's the one for you.
How about rumble ones?
Come back at heavyweight rumble,
steep pay for the curve ball.
Here's the thing,
you can't really do that because he just fought as a light to every way and then
quit and said,
I don't want to do this anymore.
When he comes back and finds that a heavyweight and he's back,
Bro
said he doesn't like fighting,
says
the rest of,
what do you say?
I don't like blood,
but I'm back.
I mean what happened was that retirement life ain't fun,
is it?
It's not.
It's boring.
Right.
And I had to spend two years and he knows he can be champion too.
Like he really does have championship skills,
you know what I mean?
He's got,
now he does for sure.
Unquestionably has enough power to knock out any human being.
Have a p if DC and Jon Jones are out.
Yeah,
he's,
he's the guy.
If DC got hit with that upper cut that Glover got hit with,
he goes night night to Jones.
Those guys are too smart for that.
They don't fight that style.
Well,
they didn't.
Yeah.
Glover was too easy to hit for him,
but I think he realizes that anybody in the world,
I mean he literally,
he might have to have a hundred percent chance to beat anybody in the world,
but he might have,
no,
not a hundred percent chance.
Do you know anybody in the world?
But I'm saying he might have like a 60% chance,
like in any fight with anybody,
he could connect with a bomb and put your fucking lights out.
He's that powerful.
So that alone in his head means like if he fought Jon Jones 60% of the time,
he might be able to catch John Jones.
It might be if he caught John Jones or anybody,
he hits so fucking hard.
But he definitely froze up against DC.
And the second fight,
he did not look like a guy who was there to do or die.
Did he hit that path that they keep jacking off to?
Did he hit the,
I would like to see that.
I'd like to see that he hits harder than in Ghana.
Ghana was a lot bigger than him,
man.
Yeah,
but the Anthony Johnson is a up more,
he's more explosive.
Especially if you put at the Johnson on that healthy diet and he's the two 40th
the Johnson.
Yeah.
He's going to hit like a Mack truck.
Very interesting to see him in the heavy word.
Ansys rumble Johnson black on black power.
Kaepernick could show up for that bitch.
You got would be rumbles.
Got To have tickets.
I'll fight in heavyweight.
It's just gossip.
Oh my God,
he's ready to go.
No,
no,
no.
You get them.
That rush and dude,
it looks to choke people
who lets people
know he's a heavyweight.
He didn't think that I'm right.
I'm right.
And that poor soul to pull the Russian has no idea.
I find black men and just fucking get starched.
Yeah,
that'll be interesting as an interesting,
let's see what happens.
I want to see what happens.
Give was that guy.
Give him somebody who's,
you know,
can we get to encourage his mouth?
They can get a choke.
The guy's going to come after him and the guy's going to come after him.
Alexia holiness.
Yes.
Howard [inaudible] Lexi.
Yeah.
Deepen his forties
same airlines.
Brian Cowen,
52 and 11 he's been through the fucking boring or you think he gives a fuck
about how hard rumble hits now.
He'll tell you they're fine.
Take foot to be all day until the BOA constrictor.
Fucking write the Bolo.
Yeah.
That would be a fun fight.
And I be my head heavy heavyweight man.
Who the fuck knows what?
If he gets rumbled down,
what if he gets rumbled down?
We see him inside mount.
We're going on a rear naked choke from the side.
Yeah.
Have was in trouble.
That mother fucker.
Oh,
it gets hold of your neck.
Rumbles in trouble.
If you get mount on him.
Man.
He like as a monster.
He's a monster from the bottom.
I'm sure he choked that dude out from his back mounted.
He gave it to him.
Crazy.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's a squeezer.
There's certain dudes that just can squeeze your neck.
And I went out rum on the first round.
Might be the most dangerous man.
Oh yeah.
Wonder if maybe look,
I mean,
I don't know how much weight he was cut to make two oh five.
But if he's really walking around at two 32 35 and that doesn't have to cut
anything,
he might be better at heavyweight.
So what I'm saying,
let's give him on that punch meter.
She got Francis just give them a good fight of her doom from overdose
dude.
For Dude,
we're doing with kill your dreams man.
Who's a mother fucker who was a mother fuck is begun.
Strike that's on the world.
On the ground.
She's huge.
Me Give a fuck about the golden snitch cause he never been cut.
That doesn't take anything.
He had some issues for doom comes on for you and that you Jitsu is just on
another planet.
Dude.
How about,
how about,
how about when,
uh,
what fight was that that backed out?
Oh,
the black beast.
Remember,
supposed to fight Derrick Lewis Fan.
We're talking about Derrick Lewis,
social media.
I used to have the best,
might be the best fucking
hilarious,
hilarious.
Shout out to Dick Lewis.
Shout out to the black beans.
Some hilarious shit.
Fight soon.
But remember,
Derrick loose was fight for doomed and the like hours for the fight.
That guy can't do it.
So this filled in random homeboy and he was just happy.
They're Walt Harris Harris.
Just a hair business lock and
just fucking some beautiful transition when it took his back and then took the
arm off the bat.
He's teaching his students in tennis about the arm,
but show it's fucking easy.
I show you how it was so easy for him.
Uh,
there's a pay day then fights that rush and goes five rounds.
That's why he won't be ready to fight Steve Bay and a Boston.